y volver a estar es para ti tal y lo que
se espera es la radicalización de las
protestas en la ciudad de quito en las
principales ciudades del país luego de
la detención de la unidad isa el
presidente de la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas de ecuador
durante todo el día se han producido
distintos pronunciamientos por parte de
los dirigentes de las distintas
nacionalidades de la confederación
nacionalidades indígenas de ecuador que
se espera bueno ha dicho que llegarán
desde la madrugada del día miércoles
para radicalizar la protesta
efectivamente ellos se han concentrado
inclusive desde el día de hoy se auto
concentrado en la sede de la unidad de
flagrancia de la ciudad de quito el dado
que fue allí donde fue trasladado
inicialmente al momento de su detención
posteriormente fue llevado a la sede de
la fiscalía en la ciudad de latacunga
ubicada en el centro del país donde
durante todo el día se ha experimentado
una gran movilización y concentración
masiva de sus adherentes leonidas iza es
el presidente de la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas de ecuador e
inicialmente había dicho que las
movilizaciones y protestas se
mantendrían en los territorios pero ha
sido la detención la madrugada del día
de hoy cuando las bases han decidido
radicalizar las protestas y han dicho
que se acercaran a la ciudad capital por
el cual lo que se espera es una fuerte
movilización sobre todo para solicitar
la liberación inmediata del dirigente
indígena han dicho específicamente que
no irán a ningún tipo de diálogo con el
ejecutivo nacional hasta no concretar la
liberación del dirigente indígena
entonces esta movilización y el
conocimiento de la situación y ubicación
de la unidad isa hacia la noticia que ha
permanecido el día de hoy en atención a
sus adherentes en apoyo específicamente
para demandar su liberación valentín ha
gustado y se han producido algunos
pronunciamientos dentro del gobierno
tras la detención de visas y estas
anuncios de radicalización
si efectivamente se ha producido algunos
abusos inicialmente también se ha
producido el rodaje de prensa por parte
del ejecutivo nacional cada hora se hace
un balance se había dicho inicialmente
que las protestas se meterían en 1721
provincias del país se había hablado de
dos pozos petroleros y que habían
paralizado pero se ha conocido también
que ocho pozos petroleros ahora se han
paralizado por el cual el país pierde
una buena cantidad de barriles de
petróleo de manera diaria de igual forma
también el presidente de la república ha
emitido dos pronunciamientos dos vídeos
emitidos grabados durante el día de ayer
y de igual forma posteriormente a la
detención de la unidad isa donde ha
dicho únicamente que irán a la justicia
y se detendrán a lo que consideran los
autores
mediáticos los autores intelectuales de
estas paralizaciones otro
pronunciamiento también que se realizó
por parte de la asamblea nacional quien
ha llevado sus plenarias a de manera
virtual también se ha suspendido
clases presenciales en más de 500
establecimientos educativos a nivel
nacional y 6 universidades también han
suspendido sus clases presenciales la
comisión interamericana de los derechos
humanos ha aceptado una solicitud por
parte del equipo de abogados de la
unidad quizás para otorgarles medidas
cautelares pero quienes le orillas y se
es un dirigente indígena ha nacido en la
provincia del cotopaxi básicamente su
agenda tiene que ver con la defensa del
territorio de igual forma el ratifica su
lucha está enmarcada en la ratificación
de los 21 derechos indígenas y de igual
forma también a evitar la extracción de
las fronteras mineras y petroleras de
igual forma que el ejecutivo nacional
mejore lo que ha sido las políticas que
han llevado al pueblo ecuatoriano a una
pobres y sobre todo en los territorios
indígenas palentinas